pienso que ya es hora de empezar a hacer
problemas que tengan que ver con
desigualdades pero en esta ocasión me
voy a tomar desigualdades cuadráticas ya
sabemos cómo manejar las desigualdades
cuadráticas y en esta ocasión tengo un
problema que por cierto saqué de la
página de khan academy el cual vamos a
poder resolver con una desigualdad
cuadrática así que pues vamos a ponernos
las pilas vamos a ver qué dice dice
riley tiene una granja rectangular de
200 metros de ancho es esta granja que
tiene aquí esta área está dividida en
dos partes una parte cuadrada cuyo lado
mide lo mismo que la longitud de la
granja es esta parte de aquí es un
cuadrado cuyo lado mide la longitud de
la granja que por cierto le vamos a
llamar l donde cultiva aguacates aquí
está lleno de aguacates y el resto del
área que es donde ella vive justo por
acá es donde vive riley cada semana
riley gasta tres pesos por metro
cuadrado en el área en la que vive ok
esta área que tiene que gastar tres
pesos por metro cuadrado no sé bien por
qué supongo que por suelo o por agua o
por luz no lo sé pero lo que ella
calculó es que su gasto total es tres
pesos por cada metro cuadrado en el área
en la que vive que es justo este equipo
y por otra parte ella gana siete pesos
por metro cuadrado del área en la que
cultiva aguacates es decir en esta área
de aquí en esta área de verde ella gana
siete pesos por metro cuadrado por la
venta de sus aguacates de lujo de esta
forma logra ahorrar algo de dinero cada
semana y justo esta frase es muy
importante ahorita la vamos a analizar
escribe una desigualdad que modela esta
situación usa l para representar la
longitud de la granja de riley justo lo
que te decía esta longitud la vamos a
llamar l resuelve la desigualdad y
completa la proposición y dice respuesta
una desigualdad que modela el problema
es y aquí vamos a poner la desigualdad
que necesitamos y por otra parte dice la
longitud de la granja de ridley es y
aquí tenemos a opciones tenemos la
opción
mayor que mayor o igual a menor que
menor o igual a y aquí vamos a poner a
cuántos metros así que para esto vamos a
sacar nuestro pizarrón déjame traerlo
por aquí ok y techo en el pizarrón ya
puse el problema así que ya lo podemos
trabajar vamos a leerlo otra vez con
mucho cuidado hoy vamos a ver que
podemos sacar de este problema dice
riley tiene una granja rectangular de
200 metros de ancho ok la granja tiene
200 metros de ancho pero bueno esto se
nota aquí 200 metros en este dibujo ok
esta área está dividida en dos partes
una parte cuadrada cuyo lado mide lo
mismo que la longitud de la granja que
es esta parte de aquí donde cultiva
aguacates y el resto del área que es
donde ella vive ok ahora lo primero que
quiero que pensemos es en áreas porque
justo aquí habla de metros cuadrados de
metro cuadrado gasta tres pesos por
metro cuadrado y aquí gana siete pesos
por metro cuadrado así que vamos a
hablar de áreas si yo me quiero fijar en
el área de esta región de verde como la
podríamos sacar
pues es muy fácil cuánto mide de lado
este cuadrado
este cuadrado mide lado el de l es justo
lo que no sabemos por lo tanto si
queremos saber el área de esta parte de
verde de la parte que destina a la
producción de aguacates entonces vamos a
multiplicar el lado que vale l
por el lado es lo que nosotros sabemos
del área de un cuadrado no hay que
espantar nos lado por lado es l por l
que es l cuadrada como el lado mide a l
entonces se le pone le va a quedar
encuadrada a ok ahora vamos a hablar o
vamos a pensar que es lo que pasa con la
zona residencial si nosotros queremos
calcular el área de esta parte de aquí
como la podremos obtener bueno vamos a
ver cuánto mide de ancho y cuánto mide
de largo porque este es un rectángulo lo
que sí sé es que de largo mide el epp es
exactamente el mismo largo que mide este
terreno su terreno completo es el m
ahora cuánto mide de ancho cuánto vale
esta parte de aquí y esta parte de aquí
la podemos encontrar de muchas formas le
podemos poner otra letra m o lo que sea
pero creo que sería mucho más
y ponerlo o escribirlo todo como una
función de l
así que si nosotros sabemos que este
largo total vale 200 metros ok y además
que este lado vale l entonces este lado
de aquí debe de valer pues 200 menos l
200 menos el eso es muy importante y
dieta es una de las claves
importantísimas de este problema y eso
lo encontramos porque yo sé que este
lado ni de él en este lado ni de él en
todos los lados de aquí miden ellen y
este lado total mide 200 metros así que
si a 200 metros es decir la distancia
que hay de aquí hasta acá le quitamos l
pues me queda este pedacito este
pedacito de color salmón que es justo lo
que yo quiero y de aquí acá entonces
mide 200 que son todo lo que medía este
largo menos este pedacito que vale el ok
y ahora sí ya podemos sacar el área de
esta parte donde vive
riley y para sacarla pues hay que
multiplicar base por altura o ancho por
largo es decir vamos a multiplicar
l l que es largo por el ancho que vale
200 menos el ok y bueno aquí podremos
distribuir l por 200 y l por melón cl
pero ahorita lo vamos a hacer en un
segundo paso lo único que quería saber
es cuánto vale el área el área de la
parte de aguacate y cuánto vale el área
el área de la zona residencial porque
aquí lo vamos a utilizar dice cada
semana reese le gasta tres pesos tres
pesos por metro cuadrado en el área en
la que vive ok es decir de esta área
ella gasta tres pesos por cada metro
cuadrado y bueno si nosotros tenemos que
estar y está dada en metros cuadrados
entonces lo que gasta ella vamos a
ponerlo aquí lo que gasta lo que gasta
es tres pesos por metro cuadrado del
área en la que vive es decir tres pesos
por el área en la que vive pero el área
que vive es l por 200 menos l tres pesos
que multiplica a l que sube es
multiplicar l
200 no te confundas no está tan difícil
si nosotros nos dicen que es hasta tres
pesos por metro cuadrado son estos tres
en el área en la que viven pero el área
en la que vive es este y esta área está
dada en metros cuadrados que es justo lo
que dice aquí ok ahora por otra parte me
dice que ella gana y déjame cambiar de
color ella gana siete pesos por metro
cuadrado del área en la que cultiva
aguacates entonces vamos a poner aquí lo
que gana gana siete pesos siete pesos
por cada uno de los metros cuadrados en
la que ella cultiva aguacates es decir
por la sangre de sus aguacates que
llegan a siete pesos por metro cuadrado
pero cuál es el área de esta parte de
verde bueno es l cuadrado por lo tanto
si gana siete pesos por cada metro
cuadrado vamos a multiplicar siete por l
cuadrada del ok de la misma manera
podemos concluir que esto es lo que ella
va a ganar y aquí tenemos lo que gana a
comparación de lo que gasta porque el
siguiente la siguiente oración me dice
algo muy
por tanto yo hace rato estaba intentando
resolver este problema y no me salía y
no me salía y ahora me doy cuenta de
cuál es la clave de este problema está
en esta oración que yo no había leído
bien de esta forma logra ahorrar a
ahorrar algo de dinero cada semana y es
que esto es importantísimo riley logra
ahorrar si logra ahorrar eso quiere
decir que lo que gana es más grande de
lo que gasta y es que esta es la clave
de este problema este problema tenía la
desigualdad muy escondida si nosotros
queremos ahorrar entonces ganamos más de
lo que gastamos si aquí nos dicen la
clave de que logra ahorrar algo de
dinero eso quiere decir que gana más de
lo que gasta eso quiere decir que gana
más de lo que gasta esta parte es más
grande que esta parte y aquí está mi
desigualdad ella ganan más de lo que
gasta y aquí está la famosa desigualdad
que nos preguntaba el problema 7 pesos
por l cuadrada es más grande que tres
pesos por l por l
200 y con esta desigualdad voy a
resolver el problema es más vamos a
apuntarle aquí déjame poner un color
neutro me gusta este como color neutro 7
pesos por l cuadrada como lo estamos
dando en pesos lo voy a poner así 7 l
cuadrada esto es más grande que tres
veces l por l menos 200 y aquí está la
famosa desigualdad que modela esta
situación ya tenemos que esta respuesta
y ya la podemos poner en nuestra página
de khan academy en las respuestas ahora
quiero que te des cuenta de lo siguiente
nos dice usa el end para representar la
longitud de la granja de riley ok eso ya
lo hicimos y después nos pide que
resuelva mos la desigualdad y
completemos la proposición ok ahora ya
que tenemos esta desigualdad de aquí que
te parece si ahora la resolvemos para
encontrar que él debe de ser mayor que
mayor o igual menor que o menor o igual
que una cierta cosa y lo padre de estos
que tenemos una desigualdad cuadrática
ahora te tengo una buena noticia
los buenos que ya sabemos resolver
ecuaciones cuadráticas desigualdades
cuadráticas perdón y entonces ya podemos
resolver esta parte de aquí o esperar es
200 menos l ya me equivoqué vamos a
borrar changos vamos a quitar esta parte
de aquí porque es 200 menos l por razón
algo me decía que esto se veía medio
raro aquí vamos a ponerlo aquí 200 menos
l 200 menos l y de igual manera aquí 200
menos l 200 menos l cuando este cambio
del signo todo saldría mal bueno vamos a
resolverlo
vamos a utilizar este color y que me
quedaría de multiplicar este por este y
este por éste bueno tenemos 7 l cuadrada
esto es más grande que 3 l por 200 esto
es lo mismo que 600 el en ok y después
13 l por menos el m quedan menos 3
l cuadrada ok aquí tengo una desigualdad
de segundo grado para resolver una
desigualdad de segundo grado yo lo que
te recomiendo es que pasemos todos los
términos de un lado de la desigualdad y
después intentemos utilizar
justo lo que ya sabemos así que este
término de aquí éste lo voy a pasar para
acá ok y este término de clint también
lo voy a pasar para acá para que todo
quede del mismo lado y me va a quedar a
7 l cuadrada ok esto lo voy a pasar a
camps con signo contrario por lo tanto
vamos a sumar tres veces l cuadrada lo
que estoy haciendo sumando tres veces se
le cuadrada a ambos lados de la
desigualdad y nosotros sabemos que
cuando sumamos o restamos algo en una
desigualdad la desigualdad el signo de
desigualdad se conserva ok esto tiene
que ser más grande déjame cambiar el
mismo color a no no no esperábamos a
pasar esto también del otro lado así que
vamos a pasarlo con este color este de
aquí lo voy a pasar como menos 600 l
ok por la misma razón y esto es más
grande que m
si este se va con este y éste se va con
este de este lado derecho de la
desigualdad me queda sé que es justo lo
que yo quería pasar todo de este lado la
desigualdad
ahora date cuenta que estos dos se
pueden reducir por lo tanto vamos a
trabajar con ellos 7 l cuadrada más 13
cuadrada es 10 l cuadrada ok y aquí
tengo menos 600 l menos 600 l esto tiene
que ser más grande que es 0 más grande
que es 0 ahora yo tengo esta expresión
que tengo aquí y ya podría empezar a
pensar sobre esta desigualdad que tengo
aquí pero vamos a reducirla un poco lo
que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre 10
de esta desigualdad y lo padre es que 10
es un número positivo y como es un
número positivo el signo la desigualdad
no se voltea recuerda que cuando se
voltea es cuando multiplicamos o
dividimos por una cantidad negativa pero
el 10 es positivo por lo tanto se quede
igual si divido todo entre 10 me va a
quedar 10 se le cuadrada entre 10
l cuadrada ok después tengo menos am
menos 600 l entre 10 es lo mismo que 60
l se va un 0 con el 0 solamente me queda
60 l ok
este país un 0 raro y esto a su vez es
más grande y el signo se conserva porque
el 10 es un número positivo que 0 entre
10 y 0 entre 10 pues sigue siendo 0 por
lo tanto nos quedamos con esto ahora
justo en este momento es cuando tenemos
que reflexionar como le hemos hecho en
los vídeos pasados tengo algo de la
forma cuadrada menos 60 l más grande que
cero de aquí podemos factorizar un poco
y decir a déjame mover un poco esto para
abajo ok
vamos a moverlo para abajo ok estuvo más
o menos así bien vamos a continuar aquí
esta expresión de que puede factorizar
una l y me quedaría el l que multiplica
bueno en primer lugar va a multiplicar
ok por ls l cuadrada y el segundo un
lugar va a multiplicar a menos 60 y
ahora ya lo tengo aquí factorizar y esto
es más grande que 0 y es cuando yo me
pregunto dos números multiplicados son
más grande que 0 cuando ocurre lo
siguiente o que el primero es positivo y
el segundo es positivo o que el primero
es negativo y el segundo es negativo
recuerda la multiplicación de dos
números es más grande que cero cuando
ambos tienen el mismo signo por lo tanto
vamos a ponerlo aquí esto esto quiere
decir que a y déjenme cambiar de color
que ya sea ya sea y voy a abrir un
paréntesis que l sea más grande que cero
que el primero sea más grande que cero y
que el segundo el segundo es el de menos
60 el menos 60 también sea más grande
que 0 ok esto puede ser uno de los casos
o en su dado caso que pase lo contrario
y que es que pase lo contrario bueno que
a él le sea menor que cero que él sea
menor que cero déjame ponerlo así sea
menor que cero que sea negativo y el
otro y el otro también sea negativo es
decir que l menos 60 también sea un
número menor que cero de lujo estos son
los únicos dos casos que pueden pasar
para que se cumpla esta desigualdad así
que vamos a trabajarlos en el primero
tengo que él es mayor que cero y a su
vez tiene que cumplir que l que l sea
más grande que 60 lo único que hice fue
sumar 60 de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad y bueno algo que sea más
grande que 0 y a su vez que sea más
grande que 60 es algo que sea más grande
que 60 por lo tanto de aquí de estos dos
lo podemos reducir en algo que sea más
grande que 60
debe de ser más grande que 60 esto es
muy importante lo vamos a utilizar aquí
o en su dado caso antes de cambiar de
color o en su dado caso
tengo estas dos de aquí vamos a ver qué
me dicen o él es más pequeña que 0 ok o
en su dado caso han dejado por acá l es
más pequeña que 60 l es más pequeño que
60 sumando 60 de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad ahora algo que sea más
pequeño que 0 y a su vez sea más pequeño
que 60 de estas dos podemos sacar
solamente una desigualdad y la
desigualdad que junta a ambas es que el
en es más pequeño que 0 algo más pequeño
que 60 y más pequeño que 0 debe de ser
algo más pequeño que 0 forzosamente si
queremos que se cumplan
ambas desigualdades ok o l es más grande
que 60 o el lema es más pequeño que 0 y
estas dos se les cumplen en esta
desigualdad que tengo aquí ahora creo
que ya casi acabamos el problema
solamente tenemos que hacer un poco
de reflexión ya tengo dos posibles
soluciones y las voy a poner aquí o el m
es más grande que 60 o el sudado caso el
lema es más pequeño que 0 pero él no
puede ser más pequeño que 0 y eso es muy
importante esta solución no puede ser
cierta porque si ella fuera algo más
pequeña que 0 tendría que ser un número
negativo y no podemos tener una longitud
negativa yo nunca voy a un terreno que
tenga menos 3 metros de largo o menos 4
metros de largo esto no tiene sentido
necesitamos una cantidad positiva por lo
tanto es cuando puedo eliminar a este y
esta es la tercera cosa más importante
de este problema cuando yo eliminó a
esta solución entonces ya me quedo con
una única posible solución que es la que
voy a poner en la página que es que él
sea más grande que 60 y me voy a quedar
solamente con esta así que es hora de
poner todo lo que vimos todo
lo que vimos y déjame a pasar aquí a la
página dice a tenemos que poner esta
desigualdad y que él es más grande que
60 esta desigualdad a ver si un acuerdo
aunque pasemos a la página y dice
vamos a poner la desigualdad que modela
el problema y decía siete veces el
elevado y elevado ok perfecto es este
elevado al cuadrado esto esto tiene que
ser más grande déjame ver creo que es
éste
ok perfecto tiene que ser más grande que
a tres por l que multiplica a 200 menos
l te acuerdas perfecto a 200 menos l ok
ya tenemos esta parte de aquí y después
dice la longitud de la granja de riley
es y nos quedaba queda mayor que mayor
que mayor que ok mayor que te acuerdas
de los metros 60 60 metros ok vamos a
comprobar la respuesta sí perfecto
tenemos la respuesta bien bueno pues
creo que eso es todo por este vídeo
nos vemos en el siguiente hasta la
próxima